and I created a 3 step process how do
you want me to feel how do you Darwin's
the blue muffin welcome everybody to
another episode of hot box and with Mike
Tyson on that in Britain and I might
guys it Mike how you doing
DJ poo in the house thanks brother it's
for having me thank you thanks for being
here man
we've also got Tony from Blue River who
does some beautiful extracts Cement WOM
Eva dabba he's a diver we'll get into
all that but man DJ poo tell us a little
bit about where you come from brother
well originally you know come from Los
Angeles California been in LA gonna have
a guy you know from the way back days
you know started off in hip hop
producing music whatnot and then got
into a film through producing music with
Ice Cube and me and Ice Cube becoming
friends and we co-wrote Friday a classic
timeless yeah we're gonna doing another
one right now so really yeah you've also
produced a ton of music yeah and worked
with some of the greats and hip hop I
started off at you know doing stuff with
a local artist but I named it King T at
a Compton California you know okay we
you know we were kind of one of the
first you know few out of Compton
California and then I joined up with
some other partners of mine with a group
we're called LA Posse and we produced LL
Cool J's bigger and Deffer album yeah
which I'm bad you know was the biggest
number one record by Michael Jackson
forever and yes and then
you know that ll keep a record took
Michael Jackson you know down from
number one it was a big album for hip
hop and for Russell Simmons it was Def
Jam from there you know just kept
working with a different artist came
back to LA and started kept working with
Ching T and then I ended up hooking up
with Ice Cube when he left NWA and then
I'll produce the you know a lot of the
death certificate album for Ice Cube and
I can tell you back in the eighties yeah
yeah I did everything from today was a
good day to the predator after our
Friday I did a film called as a little
small low-budget comedy idea called
three strikes and it did they're pretty
good starring Bryan hooks and folks and
uh and then I did another film called
the wash
awesome dude starred Snoop Dogg and dr.
Dre sweetly call what yeah yeah and uh
my role on the animated show boondocks
awesome yeah I think a lot of people out
there know ya fella those oh yeah oh
yeah I wrote on that and uh and also I
wrote on Grand Theft Auto which is oh
sweet entertainment adventure that's how
a lot of people know your voice from man
that is the biggest entertainment
venture of all times and not a breaking
records with a rare day of redemption
Manus oh yeah
that's Christ one of the most incredible
beautiful games you ever play yeah crazy
I've heard good things talk a little bit
about what you got going in cannabis
well we have a brand called true flames
that were launching out with our
partners Twila and 1500 or nothin in a
production group data hottest producers
on the planet right now awesome and
music and and they'd a real producers
man like you gotta check them out
fifteen hundred of nothing all right
you know we all we all got together and
are we launching a brand right now
called true flames and we're working
with a guy that's actually sitting with
us here today
Tony right here you know and uh and are
we working a few products out right now
do we have coming to the market like
early January
what do you have Tony we got all kinds
of stuff but I specialize in some
signature extracts if you will in the
cannabis industry and my latest creation
is the jelly and the flan and so today I
guess la better flan and how do we take
this though two ways we got this little
puff go peak might get right to it like
let's pass something around so you get a
nice little smell of something that's
good I'm sure you understand I take a
lot of pride in the extracts that we
make and it's I've been in the industry
there's 96 other-worldly that's
blueberry muffins
I mean that's what it smells like dude
all right
and then we did get another one passed
around so you can get it here's my
tractor
this is a strawberry banana goo so this
is pretty easy basically I'm gonna turn
it on and I always run out all of our
Blue River on the blue setting which is
the lowest setting you just turn it on
to the blue setting with one click
double click when it vibrates you hit it
everything's digital and it's sitting on
a quartz
so you could see it kind of coming down
so it's going to vibrate soon beautiful
just past that's not to my hair yeah
yeah you know so strong if it starts
vibrating just like right now yep he can
hit it so that stuff is uh you know
there's remember the conehead movies
yeah remember when that guy let the
fireworks off in the the kids at the
football game he had one little fart de
yeah yeah
supersonic comes yeah that's what the
flaw is like yeah that's exactly what
the starts light it just gives you the
first heads up and then supernova want
you pass that over here we'll load that
up again okay
yeah what's it taste like Mike it's nice
dude so what makes it I spent the you
know 20 years trying to perfect this
craft and learn everything I could about
the plant and ultimately from an extract
standpoint a lot of people make extracts
differently in the industry and what
makes me unique I think compared to the
rest is that I'm not using any kind of
solvents or chemicals in the process I
mean he had me when he said we don't do
it
you know chemically grow up mechanically
yeah yeah no doubt
I appreciate that too man wait a minute
and then I was already a fan of what he
was doing what is what is
I mean he's won every cannabis cup then
he probably got no room on his shelf you
know he trying to add all cool over
there but you know Tony Tony yeah I was
on the underground of cultivating
cannabis at the time mostly because I
was a patient and a victim of accidents
and opiates there at the time yeah and
that's how I stumbled upon it and became
obsessed with the plant and how can we
get this plant in its purest forms to
then learn about it and then be able to
apply that to our own human bodies and
and help us heal from within without any
synthetics and without leaving any kind
of impression on on ourselves because
the things that we put in our body leave
impressions right yep and that's the
thing mechanical over chemical preach
brother Church that's my host that's my
whole spiel right there man I love that
dude and this stuff I break when he's
ready if I ruin red you keep it right
back to Mike you weren't ready for the
ktf Oh in the morning where you I
remember the first time I gave it to him
it was like 11:00 a.m. and then by 6:00
p.m. you hit me up on her text and
you're like bro I just woke up I just
woke up yeah knock the [ __ ] out yeah hey
don't do that
Hey there you go Mike how was that
so you know the one thing I was gonna
say is that that's where these two
worlds cuz I didn't realize these two
were friends
and in the background I've been also
working with Tyson man I love Mike man I
tell you I had to tell you the story man
one time Mike you know I had a you know
low party out of the out at his house
you know just a few people over really
kicking it man and we we kick it in like
a like a little media room chilling and
Chris Tucker comes in and you know he
used to work with the foundation what
make-a-wish foundation where he would
work with that and have kids hang out
with him and stuff for the day and
really good chance to hang out with
Chris Tucker and so he had a little
young boy who had cancer and he he
brought him over and it was cool we met
him and stuff and he came to me and said
oh wow read from Friday and and he fired
off and he hit me right in the jaw man
are you serious
I'm not lying my big time and Chris look
he said hey man you can't do that for
real man and the kid looked and he said
what but that's and Chris Tucker said
man I wasn't done that if I was you and
I was looking at the kid I said I can't
get him cuz he got cancer no but you
know I just had to take it in man it was
real fun man we all laughed about it but
he was expecting you to do is go flat
and it was it was funny out there kind
of soak there for a minute I was like
that was some funny [ __ ] that's really
funny how's that uh Katie fo bro yeah
how do you feel you look good you know
yeah that's what I was just gonna bring
up man DJ Pooh what do you know about
the tow you know about it about the
towed medicine yeah that what they call
it bit fine DMT DMT yeah have you ever
traveled in not never tried it man I'm
I'm scared of it yeah I'm scared of it
and then because uh one of my buddies
was telling me about it a mutual friend
Oh Tony you know his type mcCormick he
was telling me about this dock that it
had this thing that you that's a tank
that you lay down in it and then you
take this the DMT that they scrape off
for frogs and now yes I'm sure I don't
know whatever and they're nothing and
then you lay in this tank and I was like
nah man yeah yeah yeah you had me at
this tank and I'm cool [ __ ] I'll take it
man I'm scared of that well you know
what man what Mike yeah hit it yeah Mike
did it Mike really was these you did it
brother but I gotta tell you man it
gives you what you need and just because
somebody has wait a minute so you did it
too I've done ayahuasca I've done DMT
not the toad oh god I've done DMT and
via ayahuasca and you know man it gives
you what you need you know for me it
wasn't what do I need whatever I don't
know but you know what though I know
what though if it's not something that
calls to you because I think it's
something that if you're smen to do it
mm-hmm you know it will reach out to you
know but I was telling somebody else
that um I saw something on TV where this
tribe like it was spiritual yes it was
part of it that's what it is that's what
it is man that's how you Oscar
that's how Oscar oh is that what yes but
they did like by the water yes ceremony
and in the adulation no no yeah that's
why they had that they have somebody
there to make sure they got you why are
you down in and you just flapping around
like a fish you know like they're Danae
and then they combat that might have
been like they scraped it off the frogs
nuts combo that might have been combo
it's kind of like this right that the
same way cannabis works for you right
yeah and you have this that's what I me
right and it calls out to you yes and it
balances you and it helps probably in
your creative yeah absolutely done any
ayahuasca now I'm not giving all the
credit to cannabis wait no no no of
course jealous of cannabis
yeah I know exactly what you mean
because I don't think you it's not about
saying cannabis helps me do this or
because of cannabis I can do this Canada
thank you opens you up to the
opportunities within yourself right and
that's the same thing that goes on here
so some people spend their entire life
meditating then trying to get to
Kundalini open up all these different
chakras and some people use digital
format and meditation for that and using
sound wave and frequency some people go
right right go right to the store take
you right there but quick boom
open up everything yeah and how long I
mean do you remember it everything and I
would say this to that think about it
from what we're doing with with products
here right you want the purest stuff if
you are gonna do something do something
that's natural
straight through the tenets what note
that the toad in ayahuasca is is route
yeah it's it's it's from the mother
earth yeah from the earth like cannabis
so I gotta throw some you scare me Mike
personally I haven't tried it I haven't
tried it yet either not because I
haven't been scared I'm not scared
no Mike is a [ __ ] nice and total
warrior dude for doing that back to back
like he did damn that takes some [ __ ]
balls Mount Tam yeah
back to back my hair have you done like
a wasp atony
I have not done either one but I've done
a lot well Mike you did it back to back
yeah like in the same session yeah you
did before did you get back on set then
we did it again does taste like
blueberries Tony I want to talk to you
about your process maybe don't maybe you
is it a secret not really a secret I
mean I keep it as a trade secret but
it's like any time anyone tells you this
is what we're doing even in producers in
music you
see their entire choreograph and pull up
their software still not gonna yeah not
gonna matter but in this case I did have
to create my own software if you will
you know or create a path and that came
from lots of failure and doing things
just like anyone else you're like oh I
learned we could do this with alcohol I
just take alcohol to cannabis you know
and like even with the scissor hash like
in the 90s we were trying to make these
little green balls of hash and everybody
was smoking them but that's what we
later learned what was quiz Oh which is
just like a quick wash of ice whole
propylene which is horrible for you
right right you know but in the 90s it's
like the first start of hash so that's
like that that's where the that's where
it really starts is resin from the plant
and collecting it here and then chemical
extraction was something that started in
the 90s where it was like you like us in
the United States didn't really think
about it I don't think and people
started doing that no way right and and
so that that's like you know there was
someone in the 90s that came up with BHO
extraction and the first tech that was
released to the industry was actually
something that's very dangerous and that
person later went on he's known as Indra
and he's kind of a legend that made the
temple balls back and so this individual
released tech with BHO that was what's
called open blasting and then later went
on and created actually real patents
with closed loop systems and went into
the you know I know dude I'm pretty
stoked on this this little rabbit hole
we're in here yeah so chemical
extraction really they just build a
vessel and they run a gas through it so
whether it's like ethnic Alka think of
it if you're soaking the plant material
and alcohol it has to soak for a long
time yeah and so the reason why people
use like a grain alcohol or something
like that is think of in water and
alcohol and water alcohol and hydra
hydra carbons all have different
polarities so the non polar and polar
properties of this so that reacts with
the plant and it focuses on pulling tea
see mm-hmm and so Pacific thing on that
specific thing but imagine if you're
using a hydrocarbon like a gas that
turns into a liquid and it runs through
the plant material it's going to extract
all of the things that are attracted to
the hydrocarbon and there are lots of
you know terpenes are hydrocarbons and
so there are is a purpose in a place
where these types of extractions in a
safe way I'm not saying that you can't
do it yeah the industry just had to
evolve Twitter's today to be able to do
the chemical yeah whereas ice and water
is you're soaking the plant material in
water but you're getting the water so
cold that the the glandular trichomes
heads will snap off and the stock and
you're using the ice to kind of gently
pound the plant material right to cause
a jerking sensation like if we were in a
car yeah somebody stepped on the brake
real hard we're trying to snap the heads
off and then that gets filtered through
different bag systems yeah yeah
it's not interesting well what's so I've
done both I've done both of those and
I've all I guys - yeah it's good luck I
test people don't appreciate it enough
because there's a lot of a lot of labor
that goes into that yes
and then there's products that come from
that so I had to figure out a way you
know in the commercial cannabis world
yeah how do you create a high-end
product that in our world that would be
solvent less even water can act as a
solvent washing liter beans and things
versus solvent free or non solvent and
so that was really the big challenge for
the year was take everything I know for
the last year and then apply it in a new
way and try to create a methodology and
which makes a lot more sense which is
how do we remove all the glandular
trichomes and non glandular trichomes
from the plant material and then
classify them into their types of grades
and then from the grading system be able
to pull them out and use only that
particular grade from the plant mm-hmm
and what that means is if you smell your
bud you get a little hint that it might
smell like blueberry the better the
grower the better taste yeah
kind of it the essence is there and then
it's gone you as you smoke at our time
goes on and so all of the key essence
yeah right when you look at the plant
you've got all these diverse different
types of trichomes so I'm actually going
in and I created a 3 step process how do
you want me to feel how do you dial with
the blue muffin is plan to make for my
video that's most well I feel like a
warm blueberry muffin myself holy moly
that's the key and now we get to mix and
have fun because if we know we could go
into a plant and let's say the kiwi
strawberry which we were passing around
to it has both elements in the one
strain from the genetics but really when
you look at the resin on the plant we
could pull out the essence that's Kiwi
and pull out the essence that's
strawberry and start to pull out the
purest essence of each one of those from
the rest of the glandular trichomes and
then create yeah you can taste it and we
could create and they take away that
plant taste but still do it under ate it
it's awesome man well where can people
find your stuff right now you know you
could go on our Blue River Terps calm
and you can look under our shop on our
website and hit store locator it takes
you to in California it takes you to
retailers across California that can
then sell it to you we also have our own
like delivery business that we do in the
Bay Area
let's read man what's that called it's
called next level delivery Orca NXT lvl
delivery the next TL you know delivery
hab dot-com yep Oh DJ poo what are you
up to
that's your next thing you know Tony
lame venture yeah we working on that now
but uh working on a few things awesome
man look there's not a secret to cube
and I are
are doing the right gun going through
the writing process on last Friday sweet
mouth oh yeah
last Friday yes sir I love that Oh Mike
yes any last words brother I'm pretty
baked over here until next time guys
that was hot boxing with Mike Tyson I'm
Evan Britton I'm Mike Tyson we'll see
y'all next time out of here
[Music]